okay so it's a tax planned time for
Donald Trump he had his third major
embarrassing shameful disgraceful
pathetic humiliating mortifying public
failure to repeal and replace the
Affordable Care Act and now Donald Trump
wants to move on to his tax plan and
months ago I mentioned to you who's
talking about the tax plan it says dead
in the water as the wall that Mexico is
going to pay for its scandal after
scandal no tax plan for a while and now
Trump is the sign deciding to try taxes
he announced this in front of it was a
relatively small crowd at the Indiana
State Fair Ground a great place to
announce new legislation the biggest
crowd by the way for any tax plan
announcements by a President of the
United States in 2017 that's true that
was actually the biggest crowd for that
anyway let's analyze what's in the tax
plan right I really want to get into the
meat of it or the tofu of it if you're
of the vegan persuasion but we're gonna
dig into the substance is what I mean
Trump hasn't actually explained how much
the plan would cost it's probable that
Trump doesn't know how much the plan
would cost it's also probable that Trump
doesn't know how it would benefit
working people because it really
wouldn't but that's okay we're gonna
figure those things out okay the
proposal is nine pages long and it has a
number of specific provisions which I'm
going to be analyzing with you today
let's start with the first which is
number one Donald Trump's tax proposal
would simplify the number of tax
brackets it would create just three tax
brackets at the federal level a twelve
percent tax bracket a 25 percent tax
bracket and a 35 percent tax bracket
right now the lowest bracket is ten
percent and the highest bracket is
thirty nine point six percent so in
terms of dollars this is going to save a
ton of money for the very rich how can
Republicans sell it well they'll say hey
it's going to help a lot of people who
might be in the fifteen percent tax
bracket it'll drop them to twelve so
they will sell it as this is reducing
the tax bracket for a lot of people even
though of course in terms of actual
dollars it's going to disproportionately
help the very rich we won't know exactly
what the numbers are
until we know the income income limits
for each of those brackets and I've not
seen that yet
okay that's provision number one number
two from Donald Trump's tax proposal it
is going to give Congress the option of
a higher fourth bracket if Congress
wants to pass that a Republican House
and Senate are going to say here are the
three tax brackets created by the
Republican president which are really
really good for rich people but what the
hell just for fairness let's add a
fourth higher tax bracket no way that is
therefore optics number three and now
we're really getting into the meat of
this Donald Trump's tax proposal will
double the standard deduction from sixty
three hundred and fifty dollars to
twelve thousand for an individual and
from twelve thousand seven hundred to
twenty four thousand for married couples
stay with me here okay in order to
understand what the effect is of
doubling the standard deduction you need
to understand what a standard deduction
is and in order to Anders understand the
standard deduction you need to know what
deductions are right so very quick sort
of tax a crash course you pay taxes on
your taxable income now you might earn
fifty thousand dollars in a year but you
only actually pay taxes on the portion
of that fifty thousand that is taxable
deductions take away from taxable income
so for example mortgage interest is a
deduction that has existed up until now
and depending on your income limits and
other stipulations you can deduct
mortgage interest so imagine that person
who earns $50,000 let's imagine they
paid five thousand dollars in a year in
mortgage interest that means they pay
taxes as if they had earned just forty
five thousand dollars and there's two
ways to do deductions you can itemize
your deductions meaning you go through
five thousand for mortgage interest and
you add them all up or you can do what's
called take a standard deduction right
now the standard deduction is sixty
three hundred and fifty dollars for
single people that means that regardless
of how much you have by adding up your
deductible expenses you
can take the six thousand three hundred
and fifty dollar deduction if it
benefits you you can decide I want to
itemize or I take the standard deduction
which you're entitled to no matter what
it seems like if you double the standard
deduction that's for the people right I
mean you get to deduct as a single
person an additional six thousand
dollars but the issue is that there is
some really important fine print to
Donald Trump's bill in doubling or
proposal in doubling the standard
deduction where it says to simplify the
tax rules the additional standard
deduction and the personal exemptions
for taxpayer and spouse are consolidated
into this larger standard deduction whoa
whoa whoa what what does that line mean
personal exemptions what is that
so the way it works now is in addition
to the standard deduction I told you
about a single person who doesn't have
dependents can take for example a
personal exemption of four thousand and
fifty dollars if you're over 65 you can
also take a twelve hundred and fifty
dollar additional deduction that means
that the real standard deduction is not
really going from 6350 to twelve
thousand if you're for example
sixty-five years old you're only getting
a three hundred and fifty dollar
increase in that deduction but if you're
low-income your tax rate might go up
from 10 percent to 12 percent so it's
actually possible that as a 65 year old
who currently pays 10% on their income
you might get a few more dollars in
deductions but end up paying a higher
tax rate you could end up paying more
tax under Donald Trump's plan because of
the combination of the tax brackets and
the deductions and the elimination of
those exemptions you've got to look at
the details okay number four from Donald
Trump's tax proposal it would increase
the child tax credit from $1,000 to an
unspecified amount until we know that
amount it's not really worth going to
too deeply into that but we'll follow up
once we have more information about it
number five from Donald Trump's tax
proposal it would also create a new $500
tax credit for non child dependents like
for example if you have elderly parents
living with adult children that one's
pretty straightforward
number six Donald Trump's proposal would
eliminate the alternative minimum tax
major red flag now Donald Trump is
claiming that he wouldn't benefit
personally from this tax proposal what
is the alternative minimum tax the
alternative minimum tax is a
supplemental income tax in addition to
baseline income tax for certain
individuals corporations estates and
trusts that have exemptions or special
circumstances allowing for lower
payments of standard income tax in
layman's terms the AMT makes sure that
no matter how many deductions you take
if you are really really rich you're
going to pay at least some minimum
amount of tax and the idea is you want
to prevent people who are incredibly
wealthy but through very expensive
accounting and tax attorney advice have
figured out a way to structure their
income so that it is very minimally
taxable and AMT says listen if you make
some certain amount you can take all the
deductions you want but you're gonna
have to pay some minimum level of tax
remember when Rachel Maddow did big
Trump's tax reveal right the big tax
reveal on MSNBC I didn't think it was
really a big reveal but what she did
show when she showed the first pages of
Donald Trump's 2005 tax return was that
a huge portion of the day of the tax
that Donald Trump did pay was because of
the alternative minimum tax Donald Trump
and people who are as rich as him will
save a lot of money because of the
elimination of the alternative minimum
tax this is great for the rich ok and
continuing with that number 7 on Donald
Trump's tax proposal he wants to
eliminate the estate tax now this is
super simple right you get rid of the
estate tax that is a boon for the ultra
ultra wealthy and here's what people
don't know there's already a huge
exemption for estate and gift taxes
right now you can gift or leave up to
five point
nine million dollars per person to
others as an individual you have an
exemption for the first five and a half
million dollars you leave to someone
else do you understand what this means
repealing the estate tax helps you only
if you have more than five and a half
million dollars to leave to someone
which most people do not most people do
not have close to 5.5 million dollars to
leave to people when they die this is a
provision in Donald Trump supposed
populist tax plan that only helps people
with a net worth of five point four nine
million dollars or more you might say
well how many people are helped by this
according to the nonpartisan Tax Policy
Center there are fifty five hundred
states out of nearly three million who
would have to pay any taxes in 2017
about half of estates subject to the
estate tax would pay an average tax of
just 9% because for married couples the
5.5 million doubles and becomes an
eleven million dollar exemption there
are 80 taxable estates
that would be farms and small businesses
otherwise it is really rich people who
would pay left less are you feeling
bamboozled middle-class Trumpets because
you should be let's go through some of
the last provisions here number eight on
Donald Trump's proposal reduce the
corporate tax rate from thirty five to
twenty percent and create a new rate of
25% for pass-through business income now
first the premise from the right is
highest business tax rate in the world
in the United States Trump says that
Republicans say it we've got the highest
taxed businesses in the u in the world
in the United States it's not true even
looking at the 35% tax rate but remember
as I told you earlier the rate is not
the only thing that's important
deductions matter because they reduce
your actual tax paid and American
businesses have endless deductions and
loopholes available to them so number
one it's a lie that American businesses
are so highly taxed and number two and
this is where it really gets interesting
the 25 percent rate on pass-through in
come that would help me hugely right I'm
a business owner of the David Pakman
show I make a significant portion of
what I make from the show through
business distributions which under Trump
become taxed at 25 percent instead of
one's personal federal tax rate so the
right pitches this is really good for
the little guy because all these
different businesses now are going to be
able to pay only 25 percent on their tax
rate well hold on a second about 95
percent of businesses in the United
States are pastors and they do generate
a majority of the government's tax
revenue but it's the really big ones
that generate an overwhelming proportion
of that revenue right this is all great
but in terms of dollars if you have a
personal tax rate of say 28% and you can
instead have a pass-through rate of 25%
if your business makes $100,000 a year
you save a little bit of money not very
much if you make a million dollars per
year if you can shift everything above
ninety one thousand dollars which is
where the twenty five percent tax rate
ends you save a hundred thousand dollars
on taxes with this provision and if you
make a hundred million dollars per year
this change to pass through income tax
that twenty five percent could save you
save you nearly fifteen million dollars
per year that is not economically
stimulative money because if you're
already earning that much you don't need
that extra money you're probably going
to put it in banks rather than spending
it in the local community so again this
is a huge upward redistribution of
wealth now one other real quick thing
one of the most noticeable deductions
that Donald Trump's proposal removes is
the deduction for state and local tax
this is really good for red states and
really bad for blue states blue states
pay more taxes in general and they have
more social programs if you eliminate
the ability to deduct state and local
taxes those who pay more are much more
significantly hurt by that so not only
is Donald Trump's tack
proposal one that is going to shift the
tax burden away from the very rich it's
also going to shift the tax burden in
significant ways
to those in blue states and I'm hoping
that Republicans and blue states will
say ah now you're not doing this there
might be stuff in here I like but you're
not going to shift the burden onto the
blue states including all the
Republicans in the blue states there is
no indication at all that this tax plan
is going to be good for the average
person it's gonna be great for the very
rich in major major ways millions and
tens of millions of dollars per year are
going to be going to the very rich and
again Trumpets tricked no successes so
far if Trump gets this done he can check
off the box for my tax plan but it will
be good for very different people than
the ones that were showing up at Trump's
rallies saying he is for the average
person and it's absolutely pathetic that
serious analyses of this tax bill
basically missed by the people who most
need to hear them send me your thoughts
I'm on Twitter at D pack when the show
is on Twitter at David Pakman show the
video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership